a movie about the manhunt for Osama bin
Laden ten points to anyone who can
actually tally up and count the 9/11 was
an inside job comments below props to
you for having the patience to do that
because it's probably going to be plenty
zero dark thirty so zero dark thirty s
the much talked about Kathryn Bigelow
movie starring Jessica Chastain about
the hunt for Osama bin Laden if you
don't know who bin Laden is where have
you been what I like about this movie is
it's a really realistic take on the
intelligence that leads the hunt for a
guy like this yeah I know intelligence
and government really don't go
hand-in-hand too often but this is that
1% of time where it does you always hear
about the ground troops and the Marines
and all that [ __ ] you don't hear about
the CIA's working all those people at
the desks typing away at their computers
finding [ __ ] out chasing the paper trail
when I say the movie stars Jessica
Chastain I mean this is the Jessica
Chastain show for all intents and
purposes she carries this entire movie
there are other characters in the movie
but they kind of flow in and out of the
storyline the movie spans quite a few
years it's the hunt for bin Laden I
believe it starts in two thousand three
or four as cool scene Chastain be this
really rookie CIA chick and then by the
end she knows how to do this job which
means her character development is very
good and very important you need to be
on board with this you need to be
hunting this guy with her and you do and
you are and it's fantastic however that
means other characters kind of get left
in the dust it's like oh yeah you're
helping me right now but you're kind of
expendable income your part is done now
you're gone I loved you in the two
scenes you run now there is one guy who
has more development than everyone else
maybe it seems that way because he's
ultimately in this movie from the
beginning he does most of the torture
water board scenes and that's the thing
about this movie also in making a movie
about this you feel like you're gonna
piss off somebody somehow you show the
torture waterboard scenes people are
gonna be like oh no we want to act like
that never happened that's really
offensive this terrible don't show it or
if you don't show what people are gonna
be like what why are you trying to act
like that never happened why are you
trying to hide the truth it's another
floured up version of Hollywood however
I think the movie does its job really
well in the sense that it just presents
how it was this is what went into the
manhunt for bin Laden's a really fine
line to ride that I thought Kathryn
Bigelow did that really well it's really
unsettling to watch because it's just so
realistic you're like I I feel like I'm
there but the realism doesn't stop there
the realism does transcend to ultimately
everything else in this movies movies
like two and a half hours long it's two
and a half hours of a really realistic
manhunt for public enemy number line
which also means there's a lot of scenes
in offices where people are just making
phone calls and tracking things on
computers things are happening but it's
not interesting [ __ ] wasn't gripped by
every frame in this movie I was actually
like whoa this is why I don't do office
work
I understand it's supposed to be like
that you're supposed to get frustrated
when she's frustrated and you're
supposed to feel like oh this is really
long and drawn-out because it was a
manhunt that went on for a decade it's
not going to be over like that you're so
on board with Jessica Chastain's
character that when she gets stonewalled
you're like that sucks which is a good
thing it's a great thing in a movie like
this but also in order to feel that you
need to be on the trail with or which
means you're just along for the ride in
the sense of everything like she's
sitting in her desk and making phone
calls and talking to this person and
talking to that person long story short
I'm just saying sometimes the movie
feels long all I heard about this movie
were a couple things one Jessica
Chastain completely kills it in this
movie and she does and to the last 30
minutes of this movie is the most
intense thing you're going to watch in
your life ever now the end of this movie
is really intense I really enjoyed it
and I get it and by the time they're
there you're like yeah let's get the guy
it's a sama bin Laden you know you got
to get the guy and if you don't want
spoilers from this point on don't ever
watch the news in May 2011 since you did
let's kind of talk I won't talk about
everything but you know what house
they're rating at the end I enjoyed it
but I feel like if you watch zero dark
thirty now the last 30 minutes are gonna
be like yeah yeah it's intense and real
and I watched Black Hawk Down that was
intense and real however when the movie
was over I was left with one thought
that was I wonder how the movie was
gonna end before they got bin Laden
production to this movie they were like
alright we're gonna make a movie about
the hunt for bin Laden and it was like
oh hey by the way that one movie that
you're gonna make about the hunt for bin
Laden is now the final hunt for bin
Laden yeah we got him have fun making
that no pressure I just wonder how they
would have ended it you know was it
going to be just one of those oh we're
still hunting for him kind of endings I
don't know about you but for me that
would have left me with it well what was
the point of watching this kind of
feeling so I'm glad the movie ends the
way it does long story short zero dark
thirty is well acted Jessica Chastain
completely kills it it's absurdly
realistic you tip your hat to the
respect of making the movie I mean you
look at the movie you're like a lot of
care went into making this movie however
the lack of character development for
the other characters
not Jessica Chastain's kind of lacking
and sometimes the movie feels to drag on
a bit the long drawn-out scenes make the
intensity more intense when the [ __ ]
hits the fan but it's all about is the
juice worth the squeeze that's a
question for you but for my money I will
say this movie is worth buying on
blu-ray alright so have you seen zero
dark thirty and what did you think of
the movie whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more